so there's this IRL streamer who decided
to stream her experience with cancer
live from the hospital whenever she got
the chance but after a decade-long
battle she died in mid January this is
that story
[Music]
okay so this is Stephanie when she was
21 she was diagnosed with chronic
myelogenous leukemia a rare form of
cancer that could be difficult to treat
and for years she was able to treat it
with medication and live a relatively
normal life she strained herself fishing
off her dock hanging out with friends
you know all the typical stuff that IRL
streamers normally do and once her
cancer got worse she decided to stream
her experience from the hospital
whenever she could and after a decade of
battling that cancer if she died on
January 26th when and how she found out
she had cancer and she thought she had
mono but it turned out to be CML and the
guy in that clip is Alex Stephanie's
fiance who she met at twitchcon 2018 and
began dating shortly after alec flew
Stephanie from her home in Seattle
Washington to his home in Virginia so
that they could spend more time together
somehow she got out she got out of the
time you've probably seen some of their
clips on reddit and reading through the
comments well it got a lot of different
people sharing their own experiences
with cancer and I wanted to talk to Alec
about this about Stephanie the hospital
experience and how he felt about her
sharing such a personal experience on
stream I didn't I didn't really get it
have much time with her but I was closer
to her than I have been to anybody else
before she had met me and I know that
she lived in not only physical pain but
you know justified all that it's just
cliche to say because everyone is
special but she was very special and as
their relationship grew her health began
to decline and they decided that just
because things were getting bad didn't
mean that she had to stop streaming her
experience whenever an opportunity came
up after spending time together in
Virginia's definitely had to go home for
treatment so they decided to stream the
road trip it was during the time that
she did get her bone marrow transplant
or else it would become much more
difficult to the tree she stayed with me
for about 12 days within that 12 days I
was like you know I got to go back home
we drove together from from Virginia
Beach down to the most southern tip of
Florida came up all the way through Luz
Louisiana stating Texas 20 went to Zion
Utah we had this entire journey
Ruth song one of the best times of my
life and I wanted to show her a fun time
before often and even when she started
chemo and started treating her cancer
more aggressively she continued
streaming
I mean streaming while going through
chemotherapy that's honestly an
incredible thing to do while all of this
was happening her fans followed along
online in support big personalities like
MS kiff and pokey Maine shared the
situation on their stream and even
donated money to help with medical costs
like I mean MS kit donated 2 grand
oh my god you just donated $2,000 what
what holy [ __ ] that's not thank you now
during our interview I asked Alec about
the impact that Stephanie had on his
life I used to be a terrible you know I
had I had fun but I was headed down a
dark path but I knew that if I was gonna
impress this girl she's gonna be part of
my life I had to I'm so grow up and you
know she helps me do that you know she
she kind of getting me a direction too
and look even when times were really
hard and I was down she would she would
push me to two-string because she wants
to see and after Stephanie checked into
the hospital Alec asked her to marry him
and when he did pop the question it was
live on twitch in front of hundreds of
people cheering them on
if you would marry
yeah yeah yeah
so we can get in size or whatever but I
love you in this is a sign of my
commitment
appreciation things seemed stable for a
while and the duo were able to celebrate
Christmas together but by early January
the situation took an unexpected turn
for the worse and on January 26 2020
stephanie died and support poured in
from all over social media and when Alec
was driving back home from the hospital
back to Virginia he found a letter from
Stephanie she left a note in my corner I
just found
it says to my favorite fatty of all time
I love you so much and I am so happy you
are a part of my life hopefully you will
find this randomly in it will put a
smile on your face your candy girl's
death
now obviously this is an incredibly sad
story but the most interesting aspect of
it is that she chose to live stream this
on Twitch and ask for Alec well he's
just trying to establish a new normal
the thing that helps Pneumocystis take
is you know our laundry doing a garden
and backyard streaming I have friends
come over and I like to cook food and
cooked in the forum and at the end of
our interview I wanted to give Alec the
opportunity to talk about Stephanie to
express whatever is on his mind and to
really just share some memories I know
that she would want me to continue
stream to mom it's a success and and to
begin to make people smile I'm gonna I'm
gonna honor her with as I continue life
I wear her ring my necklace and thought
a little earnings show you
man you bribed my bed I just I just want
to continue to give me hope and share
yours like he'll never stop talking yeah
I'm very thankful for this
you